a couple days ago some people on my team
reached out to some of the early readers
of my new book to see what they thought
about it and so the early readers
thought they were going to be meeting
with people on my team this is what
happened check it out oh hold on i have
a little technical problem give me one
second
sure
christy what are you doing
dude what are you doing
whoa
marie where are you where are you
filming this from
you're killing me right now what are you
doing
i am at home uh where's home like what
hey what town oh i'm sorry northwood
ohio live in bethlehem pennsylvania
ashland ohio right in the middle between
columbus and cleveland why should
somebody read this book how would you
explain like why why why you should pick
this thing up i feel like everybody
should read it regardless of whether
you're stuck in a rut in your life or
have the best life ever this book made
me feel like we're hopeful and empowered
just outside talking to my neighbor a
half an hour ago and that's all that's
what it feels like